-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"I lost a bet" stories
from you guys.
This first one is from
@ughimtiredd.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-That's a bad bet.
-No.
-This one's from @kingedhill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a good bet.
-Come on, you gotta.
This one's from @JamesBoesen.
[ Audience "ohhs" ]
That's it.
-Oh.
Why?
-That's a bad --
-That's a bad bet.
-This one from @whoopiepie10.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Lost two things that day.
This one's from
@MisterWhitworth.
Hmm.
-Wow.
I like that. Yeah.
-Yeah. Classic.
-Sounds like a syrup.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why'd you make the bet
in the first place?
This one's from
@Michaelbrunette.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
This is pretty funny.
This is bizarre.
This one's from @Clarky Lawson.
That's a good name.
-Clarky Lawson.
-This is @Clarky Lawson98.
Look at this tattoo.
[ Audience "ohhs", laughs ]
Never seen anything like that.
-What?
Is that a storm trooper helmet?
-That looks like a tasteful nude
is what that was.
[ Laughter ]
-With a storm trooper helmet.
Clarky!
-It's a tasteful nude
with a storm trooper mask, yeah.
-Yeah. Clarky.
-The last one is from @Lewan34.
[ Laughter ]
#ShePassed."
There you have it!
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.